al parecer la pandemia le costó su
tranquilidad política esta campaña por
la destitución de gavin newsom empezó en
el otoño pasado mientras insistía
públicamente en las medidas de
confinamiento el gobernador de
california fue sorprendido sin ando en
un lujoso restaurante sin mascarilla y
un creciente resentimiento por sus
estrictas medidas de contención como el
cierre de escuelas o la orden de
permanecer en casa
cuando newson cerró la economía de
california las pequeñas empresas
cerraron mucha gente perdió su sustento
nadie pudo vivir ganar dinero alimentar
a sus familias
[Música]
pero si bien la gestión de la pandemia
en el estado dio impulso a la campaña de
destitución las críticas ya irán
latentes los republicanos molestos por
sus políticas liberales especialmente en
materia de derechos del gp y
delincuencia expresaron sus quejas
durante meses que iban desde impuestos
demasiado altos al aumento de los costes
de la vivienda
marxista los líderes de la campaña de
destitución también acusan años donde
favorecer a los inmigrantes irregulares
frente a los ciudadanos estadounidenses
rico las raíces de este deseo de
destitución se encuentran entre los
republicanos conservadores muchos de los
cuales son activistas contra una mayor
flexibilidad de la inmigración en eeuu
una derrota de houston supondría
instalar a un gobernador republicano en
california
considerado el principal laboratorio de
políticas progresistas del país
por eso la decisión que están a punto de
tomar no sólo va a tener un gran impacto
en california y a reverberar en toda la
nación y francamente no es una broma en
todo el mundo
la destitución también podría significar
el fin de las ambiciones políticas de
newsom que se cree que incluyen una
posible candidatura a la presidencia